we know from the last few videos if we
have light exiting a slow medium so
let's say so I have light a light ray
that's exiting a slow medium right over
there and let me draw this is its angle
its incident angle right over there we
know and the way to visualize it so the
way to reason this out if you can run
obviously not talking about the true
mechanics of light is to imagine if a
car was coming from a slow a slow medium
to a fast medium if it was going from
the mud to the road if the car was
moving in the direction of this Ray the
left tires were going to get out of the
mud before the right tires and they're
going to be able to travel faster and so
this is going to move the direction of
the car to the right so the car is going
to travel in a direction in a direction
like that where this angle right over
here this angle right over there is the
angle of refraction and if this is a
slower medium than that if this is a
fast medium over here we get theta 2 is
going to be greater than is going to be
greater than theta 1 now what I want to
ask or what I want to figure out in this
video is is there is there some angle
depending on the two substances that the
light travels in where if this angle is
big enough because we know that this
angles always is always larger than this
angle that the refraction angle is
always bigger than the incident angle
moving from a slow to a fast medium is
there some angle if I were to approach
it right over here if I were to approach
at this angle let's just call this this
is called this theta 3 is there some
angle theta 3 where that is that is
large enough that the refracted angle is
going to be 90 degrees if that light is
actually never going to escape into the
fast medium and if I had a incident
angle larger than that so if I had an
incident angle larger than theta 3 so
let's add an incident angle like that
and so whatever that is then it actually
that the light won't actually even
travel along the surface it definitely
won't escape
it won't even travel on the surface but
it'll actually reflect back so you
actually have something called total
internal reflection and to figure that
out
what we
need to do is figure out at what angle
what angle theta three do we have a
refraction angle of ninety degrees at
refraction angle at 90 degrees and then
that angle that incident angle is going
to be called our critical angle because
if you have an angle anything larger
than that then you're actually not going
to have refraction you're actually not
going to escape the slow medium you're
just going to reflect at the boundary
back in to the slow medium so let's try
to figure that out and I'll do it with
an actual example so let's say I have
water let's say I have this is water it
has an index of refraction of 1.33 and
let's say I have air up here and air is
pretty darn close to a vacuum and you
know we saw this index of refraction is
one point zero zero zero to nine or
whatever but let's just for sake of
simplicity say it's index of refraction
is one point one point zero zero and
what I want to do for light for light
that's coming out of the water for light
that's coming out of the water let me
find another color for light that's
coming out of the color I want to find
some critical angle some critical angle
here I'll call it theta critical where
the where the angle of refraction where
the angle of refraction is ninety
degrees where it will actually never
escape so we're this right over here
this is ninety degrees and so if I have
any angle less any incident angle less
than this critical angle I will escape
at that critical angle like just kind of
travel at the surface and anything
larger than that critical angle I will
actually reflect I'll actually have
total internal reflection reflection so
let's think about what this theta this
critical angle could be so we'll just
break out Snell's log in we have the
index of refraction of the water 1.3 3
times the sine of our critical angle
times the sine of theta critical is
going to be equal to the index of
refraction of the air which is just 1
times the sine of this refraction angle
so ty
the sign the sign of 90 degrees now what
is the sine of 90 degrees and the figure
that I have to think about the unit
circle you can't just do the sohcahtoa
because this is actually why the unit
circle definition is useful but if you
think of the unit circle if you go 90
degrees we are now here on the unit
circle and the sine is the y-coordinate
so this is a unit circle so that is a 1
that's the one right over here so the
y-coordinate when you're right over here
is 1 so this right over here is going to
be 1 so if we want to figure this out we
can just divide both sides by 1.33 so we
get the sine we get the sine of our
critical angle is going to be equal to
well this is just 1 this is just going
to be 1 over 1 point 3 3 1 point 3 3 and
if you wanted to generalize it this is
going to be the index of refraction this
right here is the index of refraction of
the faster medium that right there we
could call that index of refraction of
the faster medium and then this right
here is the index of refraction of the
slower medium I'll call that the slower
medium so that right there's n s and
because you're always going to find the
sine of 90 degrees this is always going
to simplify to 1 when you're finding
that critical angle so just to keep
solving it before we get our calculator
out we could take the inverse sine of
both sides and we get our critical angle
our critical angle is going to be the
inverse sine the inverse sine of 1 over
1.1 over 1.3 3 and we can just get our
our handy ti-85 out again let's get the
ti-85 out and so we just want to find
the inverse sine of 1 divided by one
point three three and we get 48 point
we'll just leave it at 48 point eight
degrees so this right here so our
critical angle our critical angle is 48
point eight degrees which tells us so
this right here is 48 point eight
degrees which tells us if we have light
leaving water at an incident angle of
more than 48 point
eight degrees at more than forty eight
point eight degrees it actually won't
even be able to refract it actually
won't be able to escape in the air it's
actually just going to it's actually
just going to reflect at that boundary
if you have angles less than forty eight
point eight degrees it will refract so
if you have an angle right over there it
will be able to escape and refract a
little bit and then right at forty eight
point eight and this is I've rounded a
little bit but right at that critical
angle you're just going to travel you're
going to have a refraction angle of
ninety degrees or really just travel at
the surface of the water and this is
actually how fiber optic cables work
fiber optic cables are just you can just
they're just you can almost just do them
as kind of glass pipes and the light is
traveling that the in the angle of the
intensity the incident angles are so
large here the light will just keep
reflecting within within the fiber optic
so this is the light ray they travel it
larger than the critical angle so
instead of escaping it's get instead of
scaping into the surrounding air or
whatever it'll just keep reflecting
within within the glass tube within the
glass tube allowing that light
information to actually travel so anyway
hopefully you found that reasonably
interesting